[Applause]
yeah good evening and welcome so so you
can see this talk will be about mobile
C++ development for the most part
because initially this was actually
supposed to be talking about setting up
a new C++ project before Horrell
convinced me to change the focus of it
so I will also include the bit about
that but it's about setting up on mobile
super smart product so okay so this talk
when I timed it was a bit over 30
minutes with no questions so you feel
free to ask questions as we go along
you'll see how quick it goes also I
should say that we'll have a bit of an
Android focus because that's what I know
and also there's I just know that their
system native that comes up and means
two different things so it can be
confusing native for me usually means
like native code C++ C libraries but and
the mobile world native means the
platform you're on so nature can mean
Java or Swift depending on if you're on
our way sir so it can be confusing so
first thing just a little bit about me
that's my github page I don't really
have any Twitter or blog or anything but
most of my code is there and my email is
there if you need it for some reason and
I am a consultant tree tech and I'm
currently at the electrolux where we're
working on this mobile sdk to talk to
launch appliances like fridges and ovens
and stuff which I guess is why I get to
talk about this also worked on the
Android community before that and I also
got some other we had mobile things that
you can ask me about later if you want
so mobile development what do we mean by
this these days ok so this is not really
it anymore I guess
this was ten years ago there was a lot
of stuff that could be mobile
yeah Symbian was fun
so now it look like they like this at
least globally so basically only to care
about these two platforms right iPhone
Android unless let's say you're
developing for the developing world or
like places like India with this looks
very different and in India I also study
even second place but this is for the
most part what we're gonna do okay so
that development process then so Android
this is Arabic studio she used for how
do we develop them normally and you
write in Java or Co clean and open is
pretty nice language especially compared
to Java 7 which is what you need to use
on Android still which means that for
instance you can't if you write in a
list or a map you can't really have an
initializer you need to create it first
then add each element one by one which
compared to C++ in C++ is so much better
you build using Gradle or Gradle is the
stuff that area still you use you can
ill-afford the command line or directly
from Android studio using a Gradle build
file and in this file you can specify
see make file to include and it will
just use that and build the native
libraries and link those and then you
can call into this code using j'ni and i
guess some of you know J&I it's not that
fun and then a lot of the most level
stuff you still need to go back to Java
to do unfortunately except well sockets
you don't you can use beastie sockets
you can use OpenGL ES calls and sound
you can do that the recognizer so for
gaming
you can stay in C++ most of the time
which is nice on iOS you have Xcode and
I should say that like I said before I
don't really know why that's that much
but you normally developing objective-c
or in our case Swift and you can link to
native code using this thing called
objective C++ we'll get back to you must
use Xcode the world you must use an
Apple computer to build at least the
final step has to be on next count on an
apple but you can you see make here as
well yeah there's a pretty good let open
source to chain file you can use that we
also use so so far so good so do we have
any other problems so can you see me
what about the compilers so Android and
iOS default use are they both use clang
these days I'll reduce to use GCC and
that worth at least I was an option and
now they have deprecated that and they
both use lib C++ so that's the problem
it should be easy
well maybe you want to write them up of
some kind you need a user interface and
then it gets hard because they are very
different on iOS but that's not really
related to C++ but I should at least
mention that if you want to you really
want to do class cross-platform UI love
and these are the kind of two options
that people prefer there bit different
goop flattery Google's thing you've
right in dart react native is Facebook's
thing and you write in JavaScript so
we're getting pretty far away from C++
here and also at least in flutter I know
that you can't even call from dart into
C++ you need to go through Java so it
becomes very complex I wouldn't
recommend to do that
and besides you I we have I own services
which yeah we're getting even further
away from C++ yeah but these are the
kind of things that you sort of need to
think about if you want to cross
platform stuff but more relevant to at
least to what we do is is this problem
of course the language binding actually
calling the native code from the host
language this is assuming that you will
actually have some part written in Java
or for Swift and do you probably usually
need to have that okay I'm getting
nospace warning here hopefully we'll be
okay
so as I mentioned for all I know you use
Java j9 and on iOS you can use this on
the active C++ which is kind of a
dialect of the mixes Objective C and C++
but in this case since we're using Swift
we can't really use this directly even
if you have glue code written in
Objective C plus pass you need an
objective-c layer on top and for Android
is even more complicated I don't know if
you use Jane I but basically you need to
define C functions and those functions
needs to be named according to the class
name they're used from so you can you
have to use it from the right class you
need to deal with the resource
allocation you need to manually allocate
in free you it's very easy to get memory
leaks you need to handle exceptions
manually so it gets complicated so then
we come to this topic which I didn't
even consider at first I was actually
starting to write this J&I stuff and
then I just happen upon this little
project called Genie developed by
Dropbox and that does exactly what we
wanted so it was very nice you write a
your interface in an interface
definition file and you run this thing
and it generates all the glue code for
from both Java and objective-c and it
also lost like bi-directional calls from
both languages so this was exactly what
we needed
like I said developer Dropbox written in
Scala
anybody hear that no Scala yeah I went
oh good I returned right to ask you
stuff later and it's now abandoned so
that's a bit sad but it's it's a stable
product it's the longer table as a lot
of stores and users and it's a trade-off
it's a small technical debt for us and
it it does what it's supposed to do we'd
like the only sort of big caveat that
we've encountered this it has a global
object limit so you can't really just
create lots and lots of objects because
you can sort of fill up this queue
before the garbage collector has a
chance to do free everything okay so
this is this is what we have now we have
our application logic in C++ we have a
way to call into it both from from a VC
and in extension Swift and from Android
yeah when this is an image I stole from
one of them talks about Ginny there were
a couple of talks from CVP con that you
can look at if you're interested in the
genius really
so everything is good except now again
speaking of Dropbox there's this
question that I've been hearing lately
that comes from this and it's this weird
weird question should we actually do
this should we share code between
platforms when we can it's kind of a
weird question but it was what spawned
by this article I don't know if you read
it the summer Dropbox announced sort of
related to them abandoning junior of
course that they they'd given up on C++
entirely there have gone away to two
separate code bases for iOS and Android
and before this they kind of they talked
about how they used C++ to be
cross-platform and everything was nice
and this article goes into some details
about why they made this decision they
say like the signals passports
data library it's hard to since there's
no good package management the heart
it's hard to
get the libraries you want and that they
the IDS like X : understood you makes it
so much easier because they do so much
for you but they also mentioned this
problem which i think is the real
problem and it's it's know how they had
a C++ team they moved on to other things
and they have had large problems finding
new C++ people and this is true and that
at least in my experience we it's hard
to find good C++ people so if you if you
work in a company where you absolutely
can't find any C++ people yeah well
maybe then you shouldn't write C++ and
that's where the other things that they
they mentioned in this article the the
problem of finding libraries I think
that's not really true there are a lot
of really good libraries that you can
just get clone and a couple of lines of
seen a key and then you've got to go and
also the the hand-holding IDs around
that's not always a good thing that you
can just click build and run you don't
really know what happens under the hood
and but like I said if you're not a like
a popular company like a game company in
the king of unity it's gonna be hard to
find C++ people but that I wanted to
bring up this the sort of counterpoint
of the Dropbox story and that's unity
this is the unity editor now if you know
about this this is a very popular editor
for making games especially mobile games
the unit is like it's what I would like
the policy plus boss first project so
they have a player that needs to run on
I think it's around 25 platforms now so
you can't really you know bright you
then you do C++ there's no real
alternative alternative and they don't
have bindings to run jump into Java they
have the other way around they have
something called this Jane I bridge
which is an open source project can be
interesting to look at what they do is
instead they regenerate
bindings from the use reflection to
reflector with the java classes and
generate functions that you can call
from C++ instead because they want as
much as possible in C++ so that's the
other way to do it and also and Dropbox
never mentions this this is what I think
is a really huge benefit of having your
C++ code share is that you can actually
build on a PC I'm not sure they ever did
it but in our case I mean that that
means that you can you get all these
nice things that you don't get if you
just have mobile only project you can
debug much better you can use tools like
valgrind
you can you can benchmark you can yeah
much quicker cycle times you can do
write code and compile and test really
quickly and you all this this tooling
bit here we have a have written a
command-line tool for us that we can
sort of use to check things like if
someone says like hey on this weird
washing machine if we send this
temperature do this thing then this
weird thing happens then I can just seem
to sort of simulate that quick really
quickly and see see if it's oh it's it's
a problem with your configuration or no
it seems like it's a problem for us and
then we can then you can start a debug
it so I think this is if you do
cross-platform mobile you should really
even if it's not a mobile product that
fits on a PC it's really worth making it
work okay that was that was the first
part of love this no it comes this is a
bit more random this is sort of the
original talk of bits and pieces of it
so first I should maybe go into a bit
more detail about what the products are
labeled on Electrolux is so they have
they already have this mobile sdk for
for communicating with these fridges
ovens air conditioners whatever and it
has been developed in parallel in Swift
and java by two different teams and what
i got to do when i started or a bit
I started was to start we are writing
this in C++ so that's I mean that's we
really fun to do
so this participates the question
electrolux at least on this EE they
don't have any guidelines or existing
C++ code I mean they have further four
other important departments of course we
have but this meant that I got to be I
got to create this from scratch so so
but then the question is like with all
these new the new insights and things we
know from modern C++ how can we do this
in a way that don't get everyone to
agree that this is the best way to do
things I really hope that we could have
a like coding standard that everybody
agrees on sure but I will talk about
these few things there at least so first
things first I guess build system it's
kind of an obvious one I guess from what
I've mentioned before it's directly
supported by another studio and you can
build an iOS but I did look into
alternatives these the back and faithful
which are kind of children of the Google
race build system they have some really
nice properties would you know
incremental builds that are sort of
guaranteed to be correct to use hashing
instead of twelve dates and stuff like
that but in the end we went with C make
me see make the support is can you see
ly initial studio code and visual studio
these days and even if it was stuff like
but seems cool I mean we shouldn't go
with a new cool thing unless you have a
good reason for a structure so I used to
know I worked in a couple of people's
products where they had very little in
common when it comes to this this seems
to be completely wrong
so that's why it was nice when I read
about this thing some of you have
probably heard about this it's a set up
sort of guidance on how to do super
sauce product and the sort of main
article here is this project layout
conventions it was written by this guy
called the Colby Pike or otherwise known
as vector of Boo
I think he also did their CMake
integration initial studio code this is
very nice the start of this proposal
sort of this comment which I agree with
it doesn't matter just be consistent it
has really hard to C++ community more
than it has helped so he tries to sort
of collect the facto standards and the
best practices when it comes to how to
lay out your directory structure and we
try to follow it for the most part this
is like a snapshot of our directory it's
not at all complete and it's not very
controversial controversial most of it
you have a source directory you can have
a separate included erector if you want
we choose to have include files next to
the TPP fault all your external stuff
goes into externals and stuff that you
can't really categorize or an extras in
our case it's the definition file for
Ginny I also put the gym in your lair so
we can actually do this conversion
without requiring extra tools to be
installed you have tests you can have a
test also next to the CVP files we don't
do that the kind of three things here
that are a little bit weird if we
actually have a make file we also have
these generator and precompile
directories which are not part of the
standard and I can talk a little bit
about this they'll make file this is
because I really like when you can just
check something out and just type make
and it builds so this is just a
bootstrapping made file I use something
similar in a lot of my projects the
basic idea is you know you check if you
already have a seam like seam it
generated directory then you can build
otherwise you need to once you make
and it also takes care of putting the
compiled come on JSON file in the right
place which is this file you need for
for supporting IDs entirely sounds let's
not like that pre-compiled libraries
that you should avoid but sometimes it's
hard so we have a few dependencies on
things with custom build systems we only
have precompiled library for the mobile
build and then it's kind of okay because
you you know your target you know that
if you have a library it will continue
to work most of the time so the some
examples here we have curl which is our
tools and an old kind of deprecated
internet web things library called
Alderaan which is built using s cons
that we include as pre-compiled but not
on the PC build I have all Jonas build
using an external project in C make what
I will say about this also is that if I
try very hard to make sure I have the
origin or the library so I mean there is
a script that rebuilds a signal for
Android we include so the original
source code for the the dependencies
with patches that we have to apply I've
been in projects where you have the help
static libraries and no one has any idea
where they come from and who built them
originally and then if you want to do
something like switched from 32-bit to
64-bit or CPUs and that becomes not so
good
generated code we check in our generated
codes that the code that you need
generates for a couple of reasons one is
that Gradle build Java first by default
which means that when C make runs and it
generates the Java code it's already too
late
why not
sometimes you can do that I actually
started with try to do that with all
yoga but it's it's a pretty complex
thing I have still have to rewrite parts
of the s cons bills together to build
with newer and Android development kids
so it's been nobody's really used it for
a couple of years at least curl I
suspect would be possible to do I think
they actually have a see make file now
but it's not it's not intended for
inclusion in your similar yes not really
I really like to have all the source
code sort of available I might add yeah
yeah we should look into it again but I
don't think all do anything in Connor so
it's the problem is like the products
that you find in a package manager often
not that difficult to do anyway but sure
yeah generated code the other problem
with that is that on iOS we have a kind
of primitive build system currently that
sort of needs all the source files to be
available yes I think the first part
that we can be fixed actually I don't
think it's too hard to sort of modify
Gradle to do it the other way around but
we simply still have the second problem
we haven't done it so we check in our
generated code okay
this means next last point I guess unit
testing this is an easy one there was no
real contention here this is what I know
and have used and I didn't really see a
reason to switch sometimes it's easy
so packaging this is kind of the more
mobile related part of this so you have
built a native library we still need to
consume them from your in our case we
have apps that are written in in Swift
and Android and you need to consume this
code somehow and it gets a bit trickier
ja Android is Java so
that means normally you have a
repository of some kind you have you
precompiled jars or ARS that you
download and that's hard I think if you
develop in parallel you want to break
change coding in Java and in the c++ and
try things so for for that we just using
some modules instead it works not so
strange for i also have is a thing
called cocoa pods it's a swift package
manager and we need to look at that was
what I mentioned before it's kind of
primitive so we need to include
precompiled libraries and generated
sources and everything there I don't
actually know too much about how this
process works but it works for now I
would like to use C make all the way on
iOS to but that hasn't happened so far
old-style
okay this may be even bit more around
them to things but I won't talk a little
bit about naming and formatting so
naming the languages your names so I'm
just I'm curious here who prefers the
first version and who prefers the second
version it can you can get a little bit
of time to read it it's just basically
it's the same code it's just the name is
changed so show hands who prefers the
first version and the second version
okay looks like a C+ C++ audience
yeah as you might have guessed the house
would very much prefer the first version
but this is one of those cases where I
had to sort of give in to that what
other people wanted theirs yes
absolutely I my agreement is of course
for short scopes you want short valuable
dimes for if you wanna make your name
class that's used everywhere you can
think you can start think about that for
a week and like what is the actual
perfect name for this class it's really
important but there's also this other
school that all lanes should be
explicitly described what it is you
should never Jordan anything I think it
comes from those people have been
unfortunate enough to sort of work with
very junior programmers and they really
scared that they will use a rule like
this to just type short times everywhere
and they think it's safer to just say
long names long names long names
everywhere but it's nice to see that we
agree so also for some things that when
I was kind of developing this I was I
just went on you know he's like and ask
questions like this so I guess most of
you will be among that the two top
contenders here so we can try this too
who prefers M underscore for numbers and
trailing underscore okay so this is yeah
I don't think even half of you so the
rest of you what what do you prefer
we don't tell no prefix at all or suffix
the single M so it's kind of a mixed bag
I kind of like that I actually went with
trailing underscore which I was not used
to at all but seems to be kind of the
thing and also because I really like to
get rid of the last remnant of the old
Hungarian notation M underscore
snake case versus camel case yeah I'm
not gonna say much about this except
that I'm kind of on the fence about this
but we are generating Java code and
that's camel case so it's gonna be weird
if so and camel case is so far been
mostly okay for C++ code as well even if
it seems like also they didn't standard
now is that you should have seen any
case for everything and the last part of
this part is formatting and I'm just
gonna do this and say what would we have
done here client format everything space
is not tabs 80-column limit
so who here agrees with all of this and
who has a problem with a 80-column limit
yeah that's what I figured
so I guess that when you think about
this this is kind of goes together
I mean if you have one of these you
usually want all of these if you want a
hard limit you need spaces to guarantee
that your indentation otherwise you
don't know what 80 columns is and this
also goes together to do this you need
line format to make this work for you so
the other side of this I guess is people
who want hard tabs they want their own
indentation and you want to decide
decide when they break their code
themselves but I'm very much on the 80
column or limit yes okay we'll get to
this 180 columns if we break why should
we break at 80 columns this was actually
also supposed to be maybe a blog post or
a short talk I I never finished but I
wrote this script so the idea here was
that I you take six C++ code should wait
all the comments and you do the kind of
logical breaks you break out your
template curly braces on your lines but
then you strip away all the curly braces
so what you end up here with here is C++
noise without with only kind of C++
constructs that are normally things that
you either break or don't break and you
run it through plan format with like an
infinite line length and you've got a
histogram and then you will see sort of
it's really like a good cutoff point
because you don't want to put the cutoff
point too far to the right you gonna
have a lot of empty spaces just
pointless and you don't want to go yeah
two short lines because then you will
have to break many lies and it becomes
hard to read so I'm not even considering
the fact that many people say that you
should have short lines because it's
more readable like this the idea like
you know 50 to 70 characters per line is
what's because that's I mean that to be
fed as for text
books it's different for code I think
you can actually read longer lines when
it comes to code but anyway I did this
for just a few products and this is for
the Opera JSON library so here you can
see that yeah Rob Roy 80 seems to be
pretty good cut off there's a lot of
longer lines but I mean if you want if
you don't wanna cut anything then you
better get up to 200 resulting and it's
kind of ridiculous but if you cut at 80
most of the lines will not be broken
some of them will and well if you look
at other products well this is 70 here
it looks more like 90 actually so if you
want to make a case for going a bit
further up liking understand that and
this is Lou explains he called most ISO
ratio it still looks like 80 is kind of
a good place to cut so that's that's my
argument for 80 columns but then you're
you're on the team where you think you
should you should decide yourself or you
should break depending on readability
not that you should have a hard limit
and set that
there are many arguments here you can
know I didn't break much at all a wholly
broke after templates and maybe one
other thing I don't remember now but not
not I didn't do any excessive breaking
just to get the lines to be short yeah
we don't a force it I just it's most
still mostly me on the team we have some
consultants but I'm mostly in control so
far so it's gonna be interesting we if
you get to meet enough people but no I
don't know I'm not sure how we should do
that I mean at the unity they had this
the pre-commit step that actually
checked if the code was formatted
correctly otherwise he just told you
then you had to manually format I don't
know okay so this is the last part c++
17 there are code bases actually c++ 14
and it's been that since the start but
so a couple of weeks ago i decided it
was time to go to see 17 because all the
components us in supporting it for a
while and this is base basically what
happened
i've spent a week doing this and I
reverted everything after week so that
second point there we have a lot of
strings so I thought that switching to
string it would make things faster it
slowed things down can anyone guess why
creating strings maybe we have a lot of
unordered maps and a lot of maps can
only compare it using the key type not
something convertible to the key type or
comparable to the key type so yes this
was not ideal for us but it's gonna be
sold as a plus plus 20i ready with the
transparent comparators or criticals but
but I was actually not that the main
reason was more for because of things
like this
you've seen this error message yes I
think this was maybe the first kind of
the drop the major point so this is what
you get on if you try to compile it on
Xcode 10.1 at least I think so
as far as I know what this means is that
they have in the standard library they
have included over line types but they
have not included the alignment of new
so everything works until you try to put
one of these types on on the heat and
then you get a compilation error which
we do and another more simple problem
was this suddenly file system was not
available anymore and I thought of
course ah nice it's not experimental
anymore but for some reason they removed
it entirely in Xcode 10 23 it's
supposedly back in Xcode 11 that came
out I think a few days ago but I haven't
tried it so that's yeah that's the
reason why we're now back as he + + 14
again in conclusion I don't have much of
a conclusion but basically just do what
you normally do see it still C++ people
don't know about the poet's are
different does not have much to do with
C++ maybe stay is suppose verse 14 for
now maybe have separate UI code if you
have an application with lots of UI
or it's tricky to to have a
cross-platform uy and C++ code in the
same app and maybe not you see Brussels
at all if you have only UI
but a little local logic but yeah thanks
that was it
any further questions
yeah ah I should add that we basically
use
/ - exclamation mark and just oxygen
oxygen is not so good but this is one of
this I I have some ideas around how to
do that better so far and also I write
you know I just have a Doc's directory
and I put a lot of markdown files there
with stuff that no one reads maybe I
would read it when I forget how stuff
works yeah catch - si but I jumped over
that very quickly because I didn't it
wasn't really there is a version of the
unity editor for Linux nowadays I
haven't tried it there was a beta that
didn't work well but now supposedly it
work it works ok and it's if you want to
develop for other things and PC it's
nice to have good that was a long time
coming
well as far as I understand it it's not
vehicle C but a because it can be you
can if you use this objective C++ it's
that is that becomes Objective C layer
so you'd run from say 15 to Objective C
but you can mix there and then you go
into C++ so it's similar to j9 what
probably a bit easier but it's not
really my not that far actually I was
kind of settles here until somebody at
the office said I really should look
into buck so I read up on Bakken and
just Apple oh that's really cool desktop
you are normally I have not looked at
how to share that at all our UI on the
marine many years
I'm not do you mean who should decide
the interface well that's that's the
that's what Jeannie does this tool it
you just just give the you define
interfaces and it generates it for you
and you you tell Jeannie which parts you
actually want to implement and which so
you say like this is an enterprise for a
C++ class so then it only generates an
abstract Mayer's class for that and you
implement it so so that's most of the
stuff are you implant a C++ but for
instance if you want to have a callback
object rent and you can say this is
something also needs to be implemented
in in Java then it's an abstract class
for Java instead or both C++ and Java
and you need to implement it there but
it's it works really now you don't you
don't have to think too much about that
one problem of genius it it uses shadow
pointers for everything because it's it
talks to Java with references so there
is a lot of shared pointers in our code
it's price of doing business anyone else
okay thank you
[Applause]